[Musique]
du bon travail
donc votre vote heureux du bon très
bonne en aura pas ça va tu chantes très
bien gros ours
oui les enfants je ne sais pas ce qui se
prépare ce soir en tout cas notre gros
ours et informez vous au jeu des seront
voir mes deux petits lobby qui
m'attendent pour faire du théâtre eux la
porte en haut au bon score les eaux fort
j'ai apporté ma garde-robe de théâtre je
vais vous changer on appris de belles
chansons lentes et jusqu'à 3 et le
spectacle commence à quoi
sur le pont d'avignon on y danse on y
danse sont sur le pont d'avignon
owni torse le tout sans gros bébé l'info
camille st et on y suivra ça sur le beau
cas d'ignominie ghost money d'eau sur le
pont d'avignon
on y barça tout en rose
c'est une belle dame lire avant c'était
bien vrai mais la nama chacun y aborder
ce chat elle que vannades recul lui le
père lui je t'écris lui ai répondu que
non mais je n'ai pas perdu
[Musique]
or il n'est linéaire le voilà ce que ma
bourse en battant guerre américaine
abrous sort attend des recettes
ça courait jusqu'au bout mais maudit
dodeman la tendance
wipro il est passé d'une allée à la
va-vite au dodo pauvres grands sont
bâtis guerre nous on va se coucher tous
avec les autres
[Musique]
oulala mon dieu qu'est ce qui se passe à
ces gros ours qui va y retrouver nous
coucher nous aussi je tombe seule
mais oui nounours et vous aussi les
petits enfants embrasser bien fort vos
parents et aller vite au dodo et si vous
êtes bien sage
nous reviendrons vous voir demain bonne
nuit bonne
[Musique]